Now we are in the position to write down differential equations.
We look at a single corner of that braking car.
Just a single wheel not all four wheels and just a quarter of the mass of that car.
Let's called the velocity of the car V and the velocity of the rim of the wheel W.
We specify the velocity of the wheel in m/s similar to how we specify the velocity of the car,
and which will show you or rather find a discussion that uses
the angular velocity of the wheel and that uses the moment of inertia of the wheel,
which gets overly complex for all purposes.
This quarter of the car exerts a certain force on the ground, namely--
the mass of that quarter of the car times gravitational acceleration.
By friction, the road surface exerts this force on the wheel.
If you wonder about the direction, imagine that the wheel was locked
and friction will put it around in a clockwise fashion.
The first thing to be computing is the wheel slip s and given these two velocities,
the velocity of the car and the velocity of the rim of the wheel,
we can compute the wheel slip by 1-W/V.
Let's do this. I need to check. If the wheel is lock, the velocity of its rim will be zero.
W will become zero. What do we get? 1-0. A value of one fitting to the wheel being locked.
If we have a perfectly rolling motion, W will be equal to V and we compute 1-1/1 which is zero.
This seems to be very plausible.
Once we've got the wheel slip, we can compute the force from friction
and it's the coefficient of friction which again depends on the wheel slip times the force
perpendicular to that surface, 1/4 the mass of the car times gravitational acceleration
and now it's time to look at the velocities.
The car is decelerated. The rate of change of the velocity of the car minus the friction force
divided by the mass of that 1/4 of the car.
Think about Newton's law--F=m*a. The rate of change of the velocity is the acceleration.
This our force, this is our mass, and we have to take care of that we are braking decelerating.
We get a similar equation for the velocity of the rim of the wheel.
Its rate of change increases through a friction, so we've got a plus sign now.
The mass to be used here is not the mass of this 1/4 of the car.
It's rather something like the effective mass of the rear.
In reality, we would have to take care of the circumstance that the mass of the wheel is
distributed over the cylinder.
To make things simple, I'm using an effective mass here. That's my own term.
As I said before, the typical way of dealing with this would be using angular velocities
with moments of inertia, which considerably complex.
Let's cheat a little and introduce this effective mass of the wheel here.
If the mass of the wheel was concentrated at its circumference,
then this would actually be the mass of the wheel.
This is not all. We have to model the action of the brake which acts on the rear.
The break decelerates the wheel. Let me put it like that minus capital B
and this quantity B represents the strength of that braking process.
If you put it like this, it acts like a deceleration of the wheel so it's something measured in m/s².
If it wasn't for the friction force, the wheel would be decelerated by this amount.
Now we have reached four equations that describes the process of braking.